part two
all right
um
so this sort of high level where am i
going um
in the second part i'd like to move on
to sort of understanding a more general
family of estimators these are known as
m estimators in statistics but they all
have the same general form as the lasso
that we were analyzing
and what we're going to see is these
ideas that we've picked up so far
although they seem quite specialized we
were only looking at the least squares
cost function we were only looking at l1
we're going to see that there's a much
larger family of of estimators that
these same basic ideas apply to
okay but before i did that i just want
to wrap up
just a few things just because i think
there'll be some people that are
interested
from the first lecture so
i finished by deriving what's known as
an oracle inequality
right so oracle inequality says that if
if we have
any vector so theta star is is any
vector it doesn't have to have sparsity
assumptions
we solve this quadratic program with l1
regularization
then we get a bound of this form
right it has two terms that
often appear in statistical results you
have what's known as estimation error
this first term and the second term is
approximation error
okay so when you look at that you can
say okay that's a bound
and you can say well it seems sort of
qualitatively reasonable
but i think a pretty natural question is
is it a good bound
right you could ask
are there much better bounds that could
be proved and certainly there are for
instance these constants like nine over
four and two these are kind of artifacts
those aren't sharp
but sort of qualitatively we could ask
um is there a much better bound that one
could ever prove for this problem
and
the way that you can answer that is you
can answer by this is a very general
result
but we can answer it by looking at more
specific problem classes
so
one um kind of interesting set that
people look at a lot sort of the
question here is how do you relax a hard
sparsity assumption
and one very natural way of doing it is
um
you look at what are called lq balls
i'm putting ball in quotation marks
because these aren't really balls
they're not these are not norms when q
is less than one they're not these are
non-convex sets that we're looking at
but the way it works is we have a
parameter q between zero and one
and we essentially take the sum of the
absolute values to the qth power
okay so when q is one
then this is just the l1 norm that is a
convex set it is a ball
and the l1 norm is in some sense a weak
notion of sparsity if you have low l1
norm you're not exactly sparse but
somehow you're weakly sparse
maybe more interesting is when you take
q between zero and one
if you take q equals zero by the way if
we sort of think anything raised to the
zero that's non-zero that's one this is
an l zero ball it's something that
actually encodes hard sparsity
but for q between zero and one you get
these kinds of balls that look like this
they're non-convex sets
and roughly as q goes to zero you get a
stronger and stronger notion of sparsity
okay
so um
a corollary of that previous result is
the following that
if you took samples for instance from a
linear model
so y equals x theta star plus w
we assume that theta star belongs to one
of these lq balls
i don't need to know q
this belongs to one of them
the noise w has
zero mean iid sub-gaussian entries that
just means sub-gaussian just means it
has gaussian-type tails
so it's not too ill-behaved
then what that oracle inequality implies
is is the following it implies that the
l2 error of any solution
is at most the radius of your ball that
makes sense as the ball gets bigger you
have more vectors that you might have to
estimate
and then this makes sense you have a
noise variance
you should pay price if you have more
noise
and then you have logarithm of the
dimension over n
and you have an exponent
1 minus q over 2
right that exponent ranges from 1 if q
is 0 that's 1.
and if q is 1 that's a half
right so your rate slows down the
exponent gets smaller as your sparsity
model degrades
okay so let me just sketch how you prove
this this is a consequence of the oracle
inequality
so under these assumptions we're going
to show the following that the solution
with high probability satisfies this
bound
just to be clear when i write this
little less than or equal to squiggly
that just means that i'm dropping
constants that are
are universal they don't depend on the
radius or the dimension or the sample
size or q
there are pre-factors that i'm not
tracking carefully here
okay so i'll i think it's worthwhile
i'll probably truncate parts of lecture
two but i think it's worthwhile to spend
a little bit of time to illustrate
because it's a fairly direct consequence
of this
okay so um remember in an oracle
inequality we can choose this set
however we like
right so we're going to choose it to
trade off these two terms
and if you think about it the only sets
that are worth thinking about um are
sets of the following form sets that
look like for some threshold that i'll
call tau
i'm going to look at sets of indices
such that
the jth coefficient in absolute value is
big it's a juicy coefficient that i'd
like to estimate
right so this is a
subset of possible choices but it's the
only one that makes sense because
um
this thing for any other subset would be
worse
behaved okay so the only question now is
how do you choose tau what's the right
way to choose the thresholding operator
and so what you're going to do by
choosing tau you're going to keep a
subset of coefficients you're going to
estimate them
and then you're going to drop the others
and set them to 0 and you'll pay
approximation error
okay so let's play a little game here
one thing we can say right away is that
so r of q
is the radius sorry it's not raised to
the q power
there should be little q here subscript
the first thing i want to do is i want
to bound the cardinality of this subset
and
my claim is that this is at least this
large
right and why
well
it's this large well let's write it out
long hand
where's my eraser
if i don't watch out i'll pull
what mike said that i tend to do which
is erase with my hand and then
paint
right so we know that
this is a subset of these indices
there's
cardinality as tau of them and for each
of them this is at least tau this is q
here so this is at least tau to the q
right so rearrange that implies the size
of as a function of tau s tau is less
than or equal to r q
tau to the minus q
right this is valid for any tau larger
than zero
okay so that's one term that's an upper
bound on this
now i need to bound this term
so this term what can i say
um
right so this guy is equal to the sum of
things that are not in s of tau
by definition theta star j to the q
are not to the cute power to the first
power
i'm going to divide by tau and multiply
by tau
now this object by definition this ratio
is less than one
right because of my definition if i'm
not in this set then i'm
strictly less than tau this is less than
one
q is between zero and one
so if i raise this to the q th power it
only increases it
so this is at most
j in s
tau
theta star j
tau to the q power
times tau
that's using the fact that q is in in 0
1 wouldn't be valid for q larger than 1.
and now i can take out a tau to the q
and i can upper bound this by r of q so
this is at most r of q
tau one minus q
right so these are the two terms that's
important
and we've bounded the second term
as a function of the subset that's the
most this
okay so now what you're going to do is
you're going to plug these into here
you have two terms
it's going to be a function of r q of
tau
of lambda n
the way i'm going to choose lambda n is
is as proportional to root log d over n
that's that's a valid choice
and then i'm going to optimize
if you do the optimization the optimal
choice of tau is very simple
the optimal choice of
actually let me slow down a little bit
just to clarify one important point so
how am i going to choose lambda n
right i need to worry about this random
variable
what is this random variable it's a
maximum of
j different random variables
of this form absolute value
okay so what i've assumed is that w has
iid
sigma subgaussian entries
we're assuming that the columns of x are
normalized
this means that they're
you don't have one column that's sort of
hugely larger than other columns columns
are roughly of the same magnitude it
doesn't have to be unit norm
but under that condition what you're
looking at is roughly you're looking at
fluctuations of variables that are that
we're actually gaussian these would be
gaussian variables that have variants of
the order sigma squared sigma squared
over n because you have a factor of n
there
and you have p of them so if you do a
little union bound sorry d of them if
you do a union bound calculation
with very high probability this is going
to be less than
than a constant times sigma times log d
over n
right so that's that term there it just
means that i have to choose lambda a
little bit larger than a constant times
the noise variance times this ratio
so if you have that choice of lambda
you plug it in here
you have these two upper bounds and you
optimize
right you can see there's going to be an
optimization because this is minus q as
tau goes
down this blows up
as tau goes down this decreases so be a
trade off
just do a little bit of algebra you'll
find that the optimal trade-off is very
simple
the optimal tau is
up to constants is root log d over n
okay so that's the right level at which
you should threshold in your oracle
inequality
and if you do that actually there should
be a sigma here as well sorry
it makes a lot of sense because that's
essentially the rate at which the noise
is aggregating
you're sort of saying if i'm above the
noise level i'll keep you if i'm below
the noise level i'll kill you
and if you do the algebra then exactly
the rate that i i gave there falls out
okay so once you
massage the different factors of tau
into the lambda and do a little algebra
that's the exponent that comes out
okay so that's the use of an oracle
inequality
again it's called oracle because i was
kind of cheating as i chose the subsets
i mean i'm cheating
in the sense that
the method's not cheating the method is
just the lasso there's no cheating to it
at all
but in the analysis the the oracle
inequality has given me the power to act
in this oracular way and choose a good
subset to trade off the two terms so
that's why we call these oracle
inequalities
so any questions about that particular
part of the argument
yeah i have maybe two questions so gamma
depends on s
i think uh in your previous slide and
then the other question is which which
gamma
the i think it's the related
the gamma in the estimation and
approximation error that's the constant
the restricted uh
um
so
what this is saying is a gamma you think
of is a is a constant it's a some number
you're correct that when i am assuming
this re condition i'm assuming that it
holds for
for this particular s
there's a slight technicality here that
i've swept under the carpet but i'm
happy to talk with you offline about it
but think of gamma's constant typically
that's the way you'd apply this result
so the other question is related to
lambda so you you chose lambda n as
square root of over d over n yes but if
x columns are correlated then maybe a
union bound over there is loose right so
that's a very good question so his point
was i chose it this way
and this is valid because just by union
bound this is the maximum of d sub
gaussian things his point is if x has
very correlated columns
then a lot of these variables are
correlated so maybe the maximum is a lot
lower
so there's actually some nice work by
johannes laterer and one of his
colleagues pointing exactly this out
that in general that's that is optimal
in a worst-case sense but for certain
x's you should be more careful in how
you analyze it and actually choose it
so yes you can get reductions below log
d but that's only for special kinds of
x's it helps a lot in prediction error
for instance
it's a good question anything else
is yes model for soft sparseness is that
correct yes
does it come from
mathematical
reason or from a
are there some sort of real problems
practical problems where this comes
there are many practical problems so it
mathematically comes out of the
approximation theory literature it's
sort of a natural this and what's called
yeah this and what's called a weak alcue
ball which is slightly different are
both natural models
um but for instance the work of of
donahoe johnston um
when they studied you know all this work
is quite old in some sense at least
in the case where you don't where x is
just the identity and you study wavelet
thresholding for instance
when you look at what are called best
off spaces which are spaces of functions
that
are somewhat smooth but have bumps so
you can model interesting things like
piecewise linear piecewise smooth with
jumps
what they show is that the wavelet
coefficients in a suitable sense belong
to slightly more complicated versions of
these sets
so you can say if your model for some
kind of signal class is that it's in a
besoft space then when we go to a
wavelet basis it translates into soft
sparsity
so that motivated a lot of donahoe
johnston work in in the in the 90s
any other questions
why are you interested in that
particular point i guess what you were
saying is you might be interested in
finding something close to that
set of labor closers which for more
general configurations you know belongs
in one of these spaces or around one of
these spaces and here you find it
algorithmically with the last so some
approximation at that level of quality
that's basically the interesting thing
about this right
i i think
so this is the general result but it
looks a bit scary and you might say well
what does it mean
this is somewhat more concrete it's
telling you in a particular model of
weak sparsity which we can discuss or
suggest alternative ones it gives a very
concrete rate
and then
the natural question you would answer is
that rate is concrete it seems
reasonable
but you could say is that a good result
is that actually optimal
and apart from the leading constants
which are not being controlled well here
at all that is an optimal result so let
me just sort of close the loop
um by saying that
right so the point is you have an oracle
inequality that's a very general thing
you take a particular model you look at
it implies a particular result then we
can ask is that a good result or not and
we'll see yes it's a very good result
it's an optimal result
so again
mike sort of suggested mike jordan that
is that there might be some interest in
lower bounds in this community so i was
just going to talk very briefly one
could um
possibly give a whole course on this but
um
he mentioned in his introductory
lectures the notion of minimax risk
so let me just recap quickly so
i'm lifting up talking for a minute
about general statistical problems and
i'll specialize back to to linear
regression
right so the general view that one has
in statistics is we have some family of
probability distributions
we have what we call a parameter which
means that some functional if you give
me a distribution
it spits back a number or a vector or a
matrix or possibly a function and that's
something we'd like to estimate
so in my case the parameter is just the
regression vector it's it's truly a
parametric problem although this could
be you could have functions as well
um we have a metric on the parameter
space
and so the very the natural thing that
you could could ask here is suppose i
give you n samples
let's suppose for simplicity they're iid
from some p
and i ask
if i
look at the expected
error using my metric the expected
squared error between your estimate
and the parameter and i look at this in
a min max sense
okay so what's going on the max i'm
taking a soup over all distributions in
some family
all right so i'm allowing this is in
some ways a pessimistic view of nature
we're saying nature is adversarial and
nature is going to search the space of
distributions and find bad ones for us
on the positive side you as the computer
scientist or statistician you can take a
minimum and then fema over all possible
estimators
okay an estimator just means you take n
samples and it's some measurable
function of n samples
okay so this is something called the
minimax rate
it depends on the metric that you use it
depends on what parameter space you look
at and it depends on how many samples
you have
okay so a very natural question here is
i've given you a class of models
right
these are models where y given x has a
gaussian distribution let's say with
mean x theta star
variance sigma squared
and theta star varies over this ball so
i have a family of distributions
so i could ask what is the minimax rate
maybe i'll look at l2 because my bound
here was
this is a particular metric it's a
distance between an estimate and the
truth so i could ask in l2 what is the
minimax rate for that problem
right so that's my family that's my
error metric
and so what tells us here is that that
rate is good is that
essentially there's up to constant
factors a lower bound that matches it
okay so when i write little squiggles
like it me this it means that
there's a constant such that this
quantity is upper bounded by that and
there's a smaller constant such that
it's lower bounded by that
okay so that's one example of a minimax
rate
and
statisticians
mathematical statisticians spend at
least a subset of them spend a lot of
time worrying about these kinds of
functions
um
actually for computer scientists there's
some sort of interesting variants on
minimax rates
right computationally one thing that's
slightly undesirable here is this in
femum ranges over all measurable
functions
right maybe the theme is attained by a
horrible estimator that involves
exponential time search that is possible
um what our upper bound here shows is
the in in this case no a very simple
polynomial time estimator achieves the
minimax rate
but that's not always the case it's
quite possible that maybe minimax rates
are not polynomial time achievable
there's actually some interesting
evidence in sparse pca that that might
be the case
so um
okay
let me just i'm not going to prove this
but i would like just to sketch very
high level machinery that's involved i
think it could be
it should be of interest to all the
statisticians but it could also be
interest to some of the theoretical
computer scientists because
they of course spend lots of time
proving lower bounds
these are lower bounds of a different
flavor because they're about statistical
estimation problems but i think the
machinery is is somehow more generally
useful so let me just sort of give you a
high level sketch actually i know
there's some information theorists here
as well
um
a lot of the techniques end up becoming
information theoretic in nature
as you might expect
for instance one method that's used is
called thanos method essentially because
part of it just uses
an application of thanos inequality
okay so let me just sort of sketch i
won't prove everything but i think
hopefully i can convey the
okay so this is an estimation problem
by estimation i mean you're trying to
estimate some parameter a vector or a
matrix or could be a function but it's
something taking values in a continuous
space
the first step that people do is is is
they reduce this to what's called a
testing problem
testing in statistics just means that
you're trying to estimate something that
takes a finite number of values it could
be binary testing two classes it could
be m re testing
and the way that you do this is as
follows sort of abstractly let's think
about
as as theta ranges over p we get some
parameter space let's say capital theta
of p
that's a set of possible parameters we
might have to estimate
we're going to
what we're going to do is we're going to
form a
what's called a packing set
of this parameter space
so what i mean by a packing set i'm
going to form what a two delta packing
the delta is a parameter that we're
going to choose
by packing remember i have a metric on
my space
so i can take a collection of points
let's call them theta one up to theta m
and i want these points to be separated
in my metric rho
by at least distance
two delta
all right so what you're doing
essentially is you're taking a set of
points theta one theta two
around each point you're drawing a ball
of radius delta and you're asking that
those balls don't intersect right
because i'm requiring this distance here
should be greater than 2 delta so that's
saying that balls of radius delta don't
intersect
right so it's a it's a nice geometric
object
and
m is is the cardinality of the packing
this thing has a name it's it's usually
called the metric entropy it's the
metric packing entropy when you take the
logarithm
of the number of of balls
okay so this kind of thing goes back to
um
again back to kolmogorov it's it's
studied a lot
okay so the idea now is what i'm going
to do is i'm going to choose one of
these ball centers uniformly at random
you sort of think there's an isomorphism
between ball centers and probability
distributions for instance in my sparse
model if you give me a parameter vector
there's a linear model that i can draw
samples from
so i'm going to draw n samples i choose
a model i draw n samples and i give
those to you
and now the testing problem is i ask you
to solve something slightly simpler i
say just tell me which ball center
um i was drawing samples from so it's a
testing problem it's an mre testing
problem over a packing set of m models
okay
so where does the reduction come well
the reduction is in the sense that this
problem is somewhat easier possibly than
estimation
right so the intuition is if you had an
estimator that was delta accurate
then with high probability if i drew
models from this ball you would give me
an estimate theta hat that was in this
ball
and so i could just search over the
cover for the nearest ball and i could
solve the testing problem
all right so the idea is the reduction
is that if you have a good estimator an
estimator that's delta accurate with
high probability
then you also have a good test function
that will have low test error
um and that's formalized with a lemma um
i won't prove but it's it's a nice
little exercise just to work through
right so what the lemma says is that if
you look at the minimax risk here
this is lower bounded by
delta squared in this case
times the probability
over any one of my test functions
right so what do i mean here so j here
is an index
that's belongs to my index set 1 through
m those are indexing models i draw that
uniformly at random
and then
given that j is
equal to some little j then i draw these
zi's
from the model indexed by theta j
j
i equals 1 to n
all right so that's what i'm doing i'm
picking a ball center i give you n
samples
and
this thing here is a test function it's
a function that takes n samples and maps
to an index
so what this is saying is for any test
function you can try and find the best
one you
want um well i should put an inf here so
i'm going to info over test functions
right so whatever test function you do
then i have this lower bound here
right so that's the reduction
because what it says is i can lower
bound the minimax rate by delta squared
times if i can make the testing problem
hard enough that you fail at least half
the time
then the minimax rate is delta is lower
bounded by delta squared over two
okay so now what's the name of the game
well
there's still work to be done
right one is essentially a deterministic
question but there's a lot of work on
this you study the nature of different
sets and you try and devise good
packings
what you'd like actually to get a
stronger lower bound is you'd like the
packing to be as large as possible right
i'd like to have as many many hypotheses
as possible to confuse you if i'm
adversarial i want to confuse you as
much as possible so what you want is
actually a maximal two delta packing and
um
for many classes the results about the
how big this is
and then the other part of the game is
you have to lower bound the testing
error this is a testing error
of an mre problem
from this simple model choose an index
and then send samples
and so there's various lower bounds on
this both from information theory and
statistics
one of them is fano's inequality
which actually lower bounds this testing
error by
essentially
you have log of the number of hypotheses
and you have a mutual information you
get the ratio of those two quantities
that needs to be controlled
an older method people used is called
the comms method and that
in its simplest form actually just uses
pairs of hypotheses
and then it lower bounds this by
something involving the total variation
norm
okay so there's a very large literature
on this ben alluded to um it's pretty
classical dates back to hazminski and
others in the 70s um
berger in the 80s
had some nice developments yang and
baron actually in um
fairly recently are well
i'm getting old um 1999 yang and baron
had um have a very nice paper and annals
of statistics that really makes a deep
connection between these notions of
metric entropy and um
um it's sort of a very general use of of
the fano technique it's it's quite nice
to read
historically actually if you read
kolmogorov's 1950 paper
um he has a 1950 paper in which he
discusses uh metric entropies in the
appendix this is roughly six years after
shannon he's already connecting shannon
channel capacity and metric entropy in a
in a fairly deep way it's not fully
there but you can kind of with
retrospect you can see that the seeds
are there so that's historically very
interesting
okay so in this particular case there's
different ways to prove it but the thing
that you end up packing
in this case you're packing an lq ball
there's various results from
approximation theory about such packings
that one can exploit
and
one way to prove this is using thanos
method that's the way that that was
actually done in this paper
okay so
any questions about that
don't need a drink yes so the way you
define the risk in terms of this metric
you you are the the metric you choose
puts a geometry in a parameter space
which you then use as heavily in all
these inequalities so to what extent are
your the results you can get robust to
the choice of geometry you're putting on
the parameter space because you can
imagine some information theoretic
geometry on this thing you could you're
here using l2 people use l1 for a lot of
these uh distances between um
sure does it change fundamentally is
something what should worry about or not
worry about um well the rates will
change right because
if you pack a set using l1 balls versus
l2 balls the geometry is very different
but at some level they don't change in
such they change in geometrically
predictable ways
by the way what i wrote here with
squared is a special case what people
do is you can apply any monotonic
function it doesn't even have to be a
metric it can be a quasi-metric it's a
very general theory you can easily get
l1 bounds l infinity bounds
there's actually a paper by zhang and
someone else that
does this not for l2 it does it for all
the l infinity to l1 losses
the changes are kind of what you'd
expect
it tweaks the exponent you start getting
different things other than one there
but you're exactly right it's it's
geometric considerations
exactly because packings the set stays
the same but the way in which you pack
it differs
anything else
okay so um
let me jump into alleged lecture two
um
okay so so if we back up what have i
spoken about so far we've spoken a lot
about l1
we spoke about it in the noiseless case
we saw the importance of restricted null
space
we saw some sufficient conditions for
verifying it
and then we talked a bit about the noisy
case and we saw the idea of restricted
eigenvalue
and we saw certain choices
perhaps slightly mysterious to you now
why the regularizer this weight here
lambda n why does that have to be chosen
in certain ways
um what i'd like to understand now um
the time that remains i'd like to talk a
little bit about um
sort of more general perspectives
right because if we sort of look back in
many different communities we've seen an
explosion of results about many
different models about l1
about block sparse models with group
regularization about nuclear norm
regularization matrix completion
graphical models
and all of these results if we sort of
take a somewhat more abstract view
they're all of the form that we assume
there's some kind of low dimensional
structure
we posit some kind of cost function that
depends on samples
and some kind of regularizes that
enforces low dimensional structure and
and we're minimizing we're estimating by
minimizing
functions of this form these are called
m estimators in statistics and for
minimization or maximization
so we'd like to understand is
do we sort of need to rederive results
every time
like fresh or is there some sort of
common set of principles that we can
distill
and i think there is a common set i'm
going to try and illustrate that it's
natural generalizations of
certain decomposability properties of l1
and very natural generalizations of
restricted eigenvalues those are the the
key generate the the key ingredients
okay so
first lecture i was talking all about
linear regression
many models are not linear
so as a slight increment of linear
regression we could look at regression
where we have a more general conditional
distribution
but such that the output you observe y i
depends on an inner product between some
unknown vector theta star and x i
right why is this useful well
it would be useful so an actual
generalization of lasso is you just look
at
l1 regularized likelihood again you have
a negative likelihood be a convex
function
in many cases you have an l1 penalty
these kinds of things would be useful if
i wanted to modify model binary
responses if i had
you know voting data or other binary
data it wouldn't be appropriate to have
a gaussian
a linear plus gaussian noise but maybe a
logistic model would be appropriate
a logistic model essentially models the
response the probability of cena one by
a logistic function
and so you'd get a simple convex program
and you could wonder can we say similar
things about that
there's been lots of work on sort of
structured extensions of sparsity all
right so the l1 norm is basically saying
that i think coefficients are on off in
an element-wise fashion
but there are many applications where
coefficients naturally have some kind of
grouping structure and that we believe
that when one coefficient in a group is
on then others are also likely to be on
at the same time
one example this is called multi
multivariate regression so here instead
of observing a single vector of
responses you observe a matrix
n samples of
m possible outputs so you're basically
doing a vector regression problem
you have a matrix now
that's m by d that's unknown and you
might assume that
the naive model would be the sparsities
just element-wise
but a block model would sort of say
maybe rows
are simultaneously on or off in an
active manner so if one coefficient is
on then the other coefficients in the
same row are likely to go on
this comes up in things like gene array
prediction in graphical model fitting
and multiview imaging there are many
cases where that simple model is
motivated
so there's natural generalization of l1
norm
in this simple case you could just look
at the l1 norm of the l2 norms of the
rows
it's a convex function it's again very
much like a relaxation of the l0 norm
applied to the
l2 norm of of the rows
many generalizations you don't have to
use a 2 norm you could use a general r
norm you can have weights
um
your groups sometimes are not just rows
of a matrix more interesting cases that
are hierarchical or overlapping
i'm actually connecting back to if you
look at how wavelet coefficients are
sparse
wavelet coefficients naturally live on a
tree where the coarse coefficients live
high up and then as you filter down you
get finer coefficients
if you look at how sparsity manifests
it's not just randomly element-wise you
tend to see these
what um computer vision people call um
scale space trails of large coefficients
all the way down the tree
so what you'd like there is you'd like a
regularizer that was somehow tree based
and enforced groups along the paths from
root to leaves of the tree
and there's been a fair bit of very nice
work on on these kinds of more
complicated group norms
is it necessary to have all of these
models being hit by the same x
uh no that's not necessary i'm just
drawing that as a special case so yeah
the more
i guess the more general setting i allow
one x1 through xm that would be all
different and i'd have to re-block it
and write it but
um
yeah it's it's essentially the same well
it's a different model but it's
flavor-wise
yes although you i'll get into that
you'd have sort of a block-wise
restricted eigenvalue condition
it's good
anything else
um
so i'm going quickly just because this
is sort of a high-level view it's like a
trip to the zoo where we see the exotic
animals that are out there
it's an interesting problem i mentioned
in the first lecture if you want to
estimate
inverse covariances that are structured
if you assume the inverse covariance is
structured and it's gaussian you're
basically putting conditional
independence assumptions
and this is something that people call
the graphical lasso
it's basically just the likelihood of a
multivariate gaussian
plus l1 penalty on the off diagonal
edges
and so what you'd be asking here is i
give you samples from
a random vector that has a sparse
inverse covariance
and then i ask for instance variable
selection questions very interesting
here i ask when does this estimate that
i solve when does this correctly detect
the zeros
that is when does it detect the missing
edges in your graph
right so people use these models a lot
maybe sometimes non-gaussian versions
but these are graphical models you use
these to model things like social
networks or gene interactions protein
interactions and so on
and they're the edges or absence of them
this is an interesting question it's
telling you whether these things are
interacting or not
okay but the high level story is that
this is just another convex cost
function and again we had l1 here
there's been
a nice line of work on low rank matrix
approximation um
right so here
what you're trying to estimate now is a
matrix let's say it's d1 by d2
and what you believe is that it's
in the naive setting you believe it's
exactly low rank
all right so if it's exactly low rank
then i could write its svd
with less singular vectors right
singular vectors and a diagonal matrix
of singular values
so r here would be the rank would be
much smaller
more generally you believe that it's
well approximated in some sense by a low
rank matrix
and
there's a very
a simple generalization of linear
regression is what's called matrix
regression
okay so matrix regression just means
that you observe
the inner product
between
a design matrix now before we had the
inner product being a vector in a vector
this is now just the trace inner product
between a matrix and a vector plus noise
so it's a very simple model of
of matrix estimation
and this is a very natural estimator
again least squares
what is this object um did ben talk at
all about this i don't think he did
about nuclear norm
i don't think so so what is nuclear norm
nuclear norm these are just the singular
values of the matrix these are the
things that are sitting on this diagonal
this is just the l1 norm of of the
singular values
um
so it has this fancy name it's also
sometimes called the trace norm
but the way to think about it is that a
matrix has rank r
if i took the l zero norm of the
singular values
counted how many singular values are
non-zero
the l zero norm exactly tells me the
rank
but l zero norms are non-convex
and so by taking the sum
singular values are
non-negative by definition
by taking the sum or the l1 norm you're
getting again the nearest convex
relaxation
again this is a pretty old idea miriam
faisal and her thesis with stephen boyd
studied this in some depth but i suspect
probably this idea had been around
before um it's hard to tell but
so many literatures you might dig in
um one special case of this that that's
been studied a lot um ben for instance
with amanda candace has done very nice
work is what's called collaborative
filtering or matrix completion
that's the problem where your matrix you
sort of think of it as
the rows might be represent individuals
and the columns represent films
the entries here represent
things that have been rated
so people have watched these things and
give them a rating one through five
the stars represent things that you've
not observed
so we can think about this
a naive model of this is that how does
it work here these xi's what are they in
this case these xi's are matrices that
are zero everywhere except for a one in
some randomly chosen position
so if you do that and you take this
inner product then what you get is the
matrix
one entry of the matrix plus noise
and if you do it randomly you get some
sub sampling of the matrix entries
but the interesting regime is when many
of the entries are not observed you have
many stars so it's it's a missing data
problem
um for matrix for this collaborative
filtering probably this model is not
really realistic
um probably more realistic would be
something like a binomial model if you
had zero one responses or a multinomial
model but those are simple
generalizations of this
okay
here's another cute problem it's matrix
decomposition i mentioned this people
have studied a lot it's an extension of
both low rank and sparse
you imagine that you
are interested in estimating a matrix
that can be approximately decomposed
into a nearly low rank and a nearly
sparse matrix
and
depending on the application you might
be interested in the sparse part or you
might be interested in the low rank part
one application of this is actually this
problem here
um
where there was an interesting um sort
of intervention in the amazon
recommender system in early 2000
where what you had is people created
spam accounts and put fake users in
and then these fake users took two books
they took um
they took two books one was like a
christian spiritual revival book and the
other was a sex manual for gay sex and
they spammed both of them to have super
high writings ratings and they did this
over and over and over again
so the effect was that the recommender
system if you liked this christian guide
you would also like a gay sex manual
um
this won't work anymore don't try it
amazon is obviously fixed but um
essentially what you can think is
it's asking how robust are we to to
intervention so
the way to model it here would be we'd
have the matrix here would be a
perturbation in which you have a
fraction of the rows that are non-zero
you have a fraction of adversarial users
and what you'd like to do is even in the
presence of adversarial behavior some
fraction of adversaries you'd still like
to try and estimate the low rank
component that actually has a meaningful
information
so that's sort of a slight
generalization with a row sparse instead
of an element-wise sparse model
this was originally proposed by chandra
sacran at all a very nice paper a bunch
of applications it's been followed up on
by by various people and there's now a
fairly good understanding of of certain
aspects of this model
okay so there's a bunch of other
examples
i think just in the interest of time
i'll skip them the slides will be posted
so you're welcome to look at them
um non-parametric models i think
actually there are many more open
questions in high dimensional
non-parametrics than there are left in
parametrics
but let me just get back to the the high
level story
okay so the high level story is that
we'd like to sort of understand some
general ingredients of analyzing um
methods of this type and everything that
i showed you in the previous slides
um these estimation problems can be cast
in in this way
so what we're going to see is that
they're really two ingredients
one is
something that's called restricted
strong convexity it's really just a
generalization of restricted eigenvalues
to an arbitrary loss function and the
other is a certain geometric property of
the regularizers that you use and it's
something known as decomposability
they're variants of it ben uses
something called geometric
decomposability sarah van de gear has
something called weak decomposability
but i'll give you one flavor of this to
to give you the intuition
okay so um
sort of backtrack a little bit
um
in undergrad statistics um
when you take courses you learn about
things like the log likelihood
you learn about the expectation of the
second derivative of the log likelihood
that's the fischer information matrix
and then you learn about the crimera rao
bound which gives you a lower bound on
how well you can estimate things as a
function of
the second derivative of the log
likelihood
right so what's going on in in all of
these these bounds so why is the second
derivative relevant
um well the second derivative is just
capturing some notion of curvature
right so we're trying to um the way i'm
doing i'm minimizing the negative log
loss
and the way to think about it so maybe
this is my log loss
my log likelihood i minimize that i get
some theta hat
now
what i'd like to do is understand how
stable is that result right because i
only have n samples
if i perturb my likelihood a little bit
i want to see how much the solution
would have changed
and the point is that
when you perturb your likelihood a
little bit here
you don't perturb your parameter that
much there's sort of a stability result
that's a function of the curvature
around the optimum so when you have this
kind of high curvature
it means essentially that if you perturb
things in this domain you get fairly
small changes here
or actually conversely is what we're
interested in
when we have low curvature then the
opposite effects i can make small
perturbations in in the difference of
the cost function but i can make the
parameters shift large distances
because
maybe your cost function is not perfect
but if you don't know how robust the
result is for that choice right so i'm
looking at the cost function because
that's all that i know and you're
exactly right it's not perfect because
in a perfect world that have infinitely
many samples i have finitely many so
intuitively i should i should be
concerned about fluctuations in the cost
function
and if i'm trying to estimate parameters
i should be concerned about how those
fluctuations translate into fluctuations
in parameter space but fluctuations in
like the empirical value of the cost
function for the data or fluctuations in
whether you made the right choice the
cost function in the first place um
in this classical setting i'm talking
about we're talking about log likelihood
so
you could think either in the empirical
version of the population the curvature
one version is called the empirical
fissure information the other is the
population
in classical scaling these are
essentially the same thing in high
dimensions we're going to see it's very
different
um
yeah i mean a little loose here but it's
the correct intuition it's
it's spiritually correct shall we say
um
i don't know if that was spiritually
that seems like spiritually incorrect
um
okay so how do we formalize this this is
very much connected to things that ben
was talking about
right how do you formalize curvature in
an objective function
in general
you look at the first order taylor
expansion you expand it now i'm
expanding around the unknown parameter
in this case
and you require that it's lower bounded
uniformly by some quadratic form
at least in the neighborhood of the
truth
okay so high dimensions are interesting
because that that kind of picture can
never hold
right so if we go back to least squares
if you have y minus x theta squared
then if we look at the taylor series
areas the taylor series area is exactly
quadratic
if you do a first order approximation so
you're looking at a quadratic form
and generically when when n the sample
size is is much smaller than d the
hashing is going to look like this
there's going to be some directions that
are very curved
but some in which it's totally flat
these are exactly the null space
directions in linear regression that we
spent the first lecture worrying about
right so it's clear in linear regression
but this picture is generically true if
if i take any cost function let's say
that's uh
involves the sum of n terms like in a
log likelihood this hessian can be at
most rank um n when d is larger than n
so it's going to be rank degenerate
okay so the the name of the game is what
we were doing before is we were sort of
worrying about a very particular cone
and that cone you can sort of think we
were worried about is that cone
nicely aligned in these directions we
don't want the cone where the error
vector can go in these bad directions
so essentially we need to somehow slide
a cone and that cone will come in in one
moment
but let me just formalize what we mean
here's the generalization of restricted
eigenvalues
so the generalization because it holds
for any
differentiable loss function and you can
talk about it for any regularizer
okay so what you say is you look at the
error in the taylor series expansion
if your function is convex this is
always non-negative
but what you want here is that it's
lower bounded by a quadratic form
if this term were not here that's
exactly strong convexity
but we have to put this term here we can
never expect strong convexity to hold so
i sort of penalize you and i penalize
you for directions in which you disobey
the regularizer so if you somehow don't
obey the structure that i would like to
see from the model i'm going to penalize
you
there are two parameters here there's a
curvature parameter gamma and there's a
tolerance parameter tau
okay so let me just be concrete so
ordinary strong convexity is a special
case
we've already seen
a result of this form
this morning we proved a result
a random matrix result which
is
showing that this kind of condition
holds for l1
right so what did we prove this morning
we
we looked at least squares
and we showed that there's a class of of
matrices that with high probability
satisfy this condition so if you look at
least squares
1 over 2n y minus x theta squared
all right so why is least squared so
easy well the taylor error is
just a quadratic form the taylor area is
just 1 over 2n
x delta two squared let's do a little
calculation
and so what this condition would be
saying suppose i used the regularizer as
the l one norm as we were doing this
morning
what we proved this morning is results
of this form
we bounded exactly this quantity
is there a 2 or not there
i think there is not
there's not a 2.
anyway i'm very bad with constants
right so this is what we proved this
morning that there is a class of random
matrices that satisfy this
this bound
right so what we're doing is just
formalizing that notion for more general
families
right so this was we're looking at
restricted eigenvalues that's because
there's not a derivative here that's
because least squares is um
has a simple taylor expansion
there was a curvature constant and the
tolerance that i was proving it with was
again something that depends on the
dimension but this was my tolerance
squared
so that's an instance of one of these
results four least squares
but we're going to think about this more
generally we're going to see that with
many other regularizers similar results
hold
right there's nothing specific about
least squares we can do this for all
sorts of other objectives
and there's nothing so specific about l1
we can do this for all kinds of other
regularizers
right so the way to think about this is
that
if you have a convex function then this
difference is always non-negative
right so if you look in a direction
where this term is larger than this term
then if this whole side is negative then
this bound is trivial it's not saying
anything interesting
so the way to think about this bound is
it's enforcing a curvature bound but
only in certain directions and these
directions are very special
the directions where the regularizer
norm is small relative to in this case
the l2 norm
right so if we think geometrically
when a function satisfies it it means
that these are all directions in which
the ratio of the regularizer to the l2
norm is relatively small those are all
curved directions and all those
directions are good
so um
any questions about that definition
something that's sort of curious
actually um just a side comment but
this is a weakening of strong convexity
but it's not it's not the same as
convexity by any means they're actually
functions that are non-convex
but still satisfy that
and that's actually relevant for missing
data problems often you have
non-convexity and missing data problems
um
so it's not exactly the same as it's not
a subset of convex functions it sort of
intersects certain convex functions but
includes non-convex things as well
and uh geometrically how can that happen
well just imagine instead of being flat
here i had a saddle function that
started going down
right i can still be nicely curved in
certain directions and have negative
eigenvalues let's say in other
directions that's a non-convex function
it kind of is a monkey saddle but it can
still satisfy this definition
so it's sort of an interesting class of
it's an interesting condition actually
is from an optimization point of view
it's it's related to some
there's related definitions of similar
things in some optimization theory
okay
um
so
what can you say in terms of
optimization
can you can you optimize them
yeah so
yes you can optimize them but um
yeah so what you can do is you can
optimize them quickly as in
geometrically fast up to a small
neighborhood around the optimum
and the reason you can do that
is because
as optimization problems as long as i
can sure the algorithm always moves in
these directions it looks like a
strongly convex problem
but um what happens eventually is that
as you get very close to the optimum
some of these directions start to
intrude so there's a certain radius of
those directions
once you're inside that small radius you
can't optimize quickly anymore but
actually for many problems you can prove
that that radius is so small
that it's below the statistical noise
so from a statistical point of view
you'd never want to optimize beyond that
precision
um but yes there is ben went through
yesterday a sort of quick version of
he did gradient descent and
contractivity
what this gives you is not global
contractivity but it gives you
contractivity in certain directions and
that's enough to prove fast geometric
convergence to a point that's a great
question
yes another question maybe maybe you're
going to get to it right so i guess what
is the so obviously it's this class of
loss functions is more general than loss
function starts by strong complexity but
what is the is the
i mean i guess it goes back to his
sebastian's question is there is the
intent here to try and define a larger
class where you can optimize well in a
way that sort of aligns yourself with
the regularizer just by by design
because what is the
um so the primary focus here this has
consequences for optimization but the
primary focus is to prove statistical
error bounds
right so what we'd like to do what our
goal is
is you give me this
i'm going to assume that the popul the
minimizer of the population version of
this let's call that theta star let's
say it's unique i want to give bounds on
how far away this is from that
population minimizer as a function of
the structure
so i want to do this generally that's
exactly what we did for
least squares and l1 and sparse vectors
i want to do this in some generality so
the point is that if you want to prove
those bounds
you can never expect strong convexity
but this is a weakening that does hold
for many models with high probability
and this is something that's useful
so that's that's the gist of it
um
okay so just uh
right so understand if you understand re
restricted eigenvalue you understand
this notion because
restricted eigenvalues just pop out in
the special case of least squares it's
exactly the same intuition it's a lower
bound on curvature in certain directions
i think i'll skip this
i actually know let me state it quickly
but just to give you a sense i've been
talking all linear models but let's talk
a somewhat more general family of models
let's talk about what are called
generalized linear models
right so these are models in which we
have a conditional distribution of a
response given covariates
that depends on the inner product
between the covariates and some vector
that's unknown it's it's a generalized
regression vector
and then we have a kind of exponential
family of this form
okay so why are these statisticians like
this they like it because it includes
many models we already know about
if you make this function t squared over
two you get a linear gaussian model
if you make this function log the
logistic function you get logistic model
for binary response data
if you make it e to the t you get
poisson
data so there's many models many
different kinds of data that we can
model in this way
so
here's sort of a general result on
strong convexity
so we'll look at any regularizer that's
a norm
um it has to dominate the l2 norm so it
could be the l1
dominates just means that it's in
general larger than the l2 norm so l1
group sparse norms nuclear norms all of
these things are dominant in that sense
there's some interesting duality theory
here it's related to what ben was
speaking about this morning
it turns out that so if you have a
regularizer you can look at its dual the
dual of a of a norm so if i have l one i
get l infinity
if i have a nuclear norm nuclear norm is
maximum singular value
sorry is some of the singular values and
the dual norm is the maximum singular
value the operator norm so any norm we
have a dual norm i'll call r star
um you look at what's called a kind of
radamacro complexity it's a way of
measuring how large is this ball
so you look at directions you take a
worse case over all directions in your
unit ball
and you look at this random variable
these are your covariates and these are
random sine variables that's something
known as a rather macro complexity it
comes up a lot
in empirical processes
so here's a general result there's
actually no assumptions on the
covariates other than their iid
what it says is that your empirical
taylor area error will be bounded by the
population quantity
then minus the term that's of this form
and then t here we have to plug into
this equation
it says you need to choose t so that to
make your probability small it has to be
somewhat larger than this random
variable here
that's sort of a uniform law
holds for
least squares logistic multinomial all
of these things
and essentially it reduces the problem
of finding out this is the tolerance
term right here
to find the tolerance term you just have
to analyze this random variable
and that that's a very geometric thing
right what is that doing
that's sort of saying let's look with
these random signs and your covariates
let's look how far you can move out in a
certain direction in your in your unit
ball
all right so for the l one ball this
would be an l infinity norm
for a nuclear normal ball that would be
an operator normal
okay
all right so what that is showing is it
showing that in many cases we can check
that these kinds of conditions hold
so from now i'm sort of going to assume
this condition holds
and i'm going to explore the
consequences of it
and there's one more ingredient that we
need
and that's this notion of
decomposability so let me move on to
that
okay so up to now we've been talking
purely about the cost function we've
been saying i want the cost function to
be
satisfied this notion of being curved in
some directions
um
if you think about it the directions
that are good here
right remember the directions are good
are directions in which the regularizer
is small relative to the l2 norm
so what i need is i need some way of
translating between these two norms
and to do that i need a geometric
property that's known as decomposability
so what i'm doing here is i'm just
formalizing the fact that when you take
the l1 norm
it always splits into two parts one part
is the l if i take a subset i can split
it into l one norm on the subset plus l
one norm on the subset complement it
decomposes exactly across those pairs of
vectors
i just want to formalize this for more
general losses
and so the
the way we do this is we sort of imagine
there's some subspace
we think about as a model subspace it's
where you think your model
vector or matrix might lie
and there's a complementary subspace
which
is um in some sense bad directions those
are things we want to exclude
and what we'd like we're going to look
at regularizers that are norms you want
norms you want pairs of subspaces
so that when you take something blue
that's in the good space and something
in the bad space
you want that
essentially you can break the norm into
two pieces and hit it separately on
alpha and separately on beta
right so it's sort of saying for all
pairs of vectors in these two subspaces
your norm decomposes it breaks into
terms on the two subspaces
all right so it's obvious that l1
satisfies this
because if you take s sparse vectors and
things that are supported off s it
breaks in exactly this way
what's more interesting is the nuclear
norm on matrix space is also
decomposable
that's not totally obvious to see you
have to construct the right subspaces
but what you can show is if you take a
certain space of low rank matrices
and you define a certain complement in
the right way again the nuclear norm
will split the singular values will
split in the right way
so essentially if you look at the
analyses of all these kinds of norms
they're all using this decomposability
property at some point and
and there's some relaxations that this
notion of weak decomposability of sarah
van de gear is one
okay
so those are two ingredients it's a
certain property of a cost function a
certain geometric property of a
regularizer what can you say when this
happens
well
why is decomposability important
this is the generalization of the cone
that we were looking at this morning
so what decomposability guarantees
is
that if you take lambda n large enough
remember lambda n is your regularization
weight
if you take it large enough then for any
one of these regularizers there's a very
special set
that your error vector has to belong to
okay so what are we doing
all right so we're looking at this
optimization problem
we've got this cost function depends on
the data
well this is some parameter space it
could be a matrix space
but a regularizer
we're assuming a restricted strong
convexity condition
on the taylor series
error
right that's the property of the loss
function i want this to be bigger than
some gamma times the two norms squared
time minus some tolerance squared of the
regularizer
have decomposability
and so now what we're addressing is
we're addressing how large should this
quantity be
what's the minimal setting of that
quantity
and
this is essentially the the correct way
to set these in
in a variety of problems
okay so i have a a regularizer that's a
norm
so i have a dual norm
r star
okay so this is concrete examples
l one would translate to l infinity for
vectors
um
if i had a nuclear norm on matrix space
as my regularizer that would translate
to an operator norm
maximum singular value for matrices
right those are two examples of dual
norm pairs
so what the theory says is whatever norm
you regularize with first compute the
dual norm
and then what you should do is you look
at the score function of your model
the score function is just a fancy name
for the derivative of the cost function
evaluated at the true parameter
okay so when your model is well
specified
that is going to be a zero mean random
variable
because we're assuming that if i had
infinite samples and theta star
minimizes it
so in expectation the score function
that derivative should be zero mean
and then what you're saying is you
should measure the fluctuations of the
score function in terms of the dual norm
and you should make lambda n a little
bigger than those fluctuations
okay and if you do that then good things
happen and what are the good things
there's always some cone it's not always
a polyhedral cone but there's some
abstract cone
and you're guaranteed that your solution
and the truth the difference between
them lies in a very specific direction
right so that's why decomposability is
important
decomposability and
this choice of lambda n that's called
the dual norm bound choice of lambda n
for obvious reasons
it's sort of saying the way noise
aggregates in these models is according
to the dual of your regularizer
right and you can understand
just to connect to the theory i was
giving you this morning
and see why it's a special case
all right so let's go back to least
squares i was talking only about these
squares
and i was talking only about l1
all right so we had least squares and
so our dual norm here
is the l infinity norm
and what was what were my choices this
morning i was telling you that you
should choose lambda n to be somewhat
larger than 2
times x transpose w over n
infinity
right so that that dual norm is
that's a special case of this
and for a linear model if you compute
the score function
for a linear model with least squares
this is exactly the score function
that's the noise
right so what we did for l1
is just a special case the the general
story is look at dual norms and then
choose the the regularizer in this way
any questions about that
i think if you want to understand the
intuition by the way at least i
personally like pictures but this
picture
and this one
earlier are essentially it right
this is a picture of a generic high
dimensional loss function it has bad
directions and good directions
all you want to have happen and what you
do in these proofs is you spend your
time certifying that
some cone-like set always aligns nicely
in the good directions
right it's essentially a geometric thing
it's bad directions good directions and
cones and aligning them properly
yeah so this the function can be very
not complex because you have the
regulation term which controls that you
also said that you use this to find an
optimum up to a ball
yes optimum
if the function is not convex may not
even have a minimum it goes down like
that so it's not like so you're finding
the optimal not the original function
but a regularized thing up to that ball
okay so to be clear here i am assuming
in addition that l is convex
there is more general theory that allows
l to be non-convex as long as it's
restrictedly strongly convex the proof
techniques are different and you're
correct there are issues because if you
have a non-convex function you could
escape
off one of the slopes downwards so there
are some more technicalities but roughly
speaking the the results go through
yeah here throughout i'm assuming l is
convex and r is decomposable that's used
um
to prove this uh
a number of times yep
yes where is m tilde
yeah so i've swept something under the
rug a little bit here for pedagogical
reasons
um there are many norms that decompose
across m and m twiddle or m complement
but if you want to handle more general
norms like nuclear norm you have to
introduce a third subspace that's a
little bit bigger than m
and we call that m twiddle
um so this is a general result that i
think i deleted m twiddle from
everywhere but yeah for nuclear norm
there's a slight augmentation of the
definition but the intuition is the same
anything else
okay
so here's some examples of verifying
this i'll leave them in the slides but
let me just state a theorem
again this is a deterministic theorem
from an optimizer point of view it's a
theorem really about stability of an
optimization problem
right so what the theorem says is solve
this program it's going to be a convex
program with a convex loss and a
regularizer
we're assuming that you have this gamma
tau
rsc condition
on your loss function with respect to
the regularizer depends on the
regularizer
and here's the first theorem the first
theorem says
the first form of it
says the following it says that suppose
you have a subspace m
in which your true parameter belongs
right so in the case of sparse vectors
that we did this morning this would be a
subspace of vectors that have a fixed
support
it says
suppose this is less than one i'll come
back to that
it says be sure that you choose your
lambda n big enough you lambda n has to
satisfy the dual norm bound
and then what it says is that any
solution in squared l2 norm
has error that's at most the regularizer
squared
one over the curvature
squared so you have a curvature here
you have larger curvature you get a
better error
and a third quantity which is a
geometric quantity
which just measures when you look at
your model subspace and you ask how much
bigger can your regularizer be than your
norm on that space
okay
this is like a lipschitz constant it
measures how large can the regularizer
be compared to the l2 norm
in a worst case sense over the subspace
over which you're trying to estimate
okay
so the intuition here is as m gets
bigger this quantity gets bigger if you
try and estimate more complicated models
you're going to pay a price
the intuition here is that this is the
score function it assesses how much
fluctuation how much noise is there in
your data if your variance grows
this term is going to grow so you're
going to pay a price with the variance
here
the third term is this curvature if your
loss function is more curved it should
be an easier problem and so the error
should be inversely proportional to that
okay so let me just rederive the lasso
very quickly as a corollary right so for
lesu what's your model subspace you take
m of s it's a set of vectors in r of d
that
are equal to zero when you're not on
that subset
right that's a subspace
um if i compute this psi squared of m
quantity it's the soup of vectors of the
l1 norm
over the l2 norm
right so these guys are s sparse so
what's the worst case we did this
calculation this morning the worst case
is root s
um i already computed if i did least
squares with l one then r star of the
score function
for a least squares loss would have been
x transpose w over n
infinity norm
all right so as from the lasso corollary
and we argued that in many cases this
random variable is upper bounded by
sigma times log d over n with high
probability
so it means if you set lambda n
a constant multiple of this
and i plug in the pieces then
immediately you get this bound
all right so that's a special case
um
and the point here is not to have
rederived the lasso in a very
complicated way
the point is that that applies to the
lasso but applies to many other things
and the rates that you will get out when
you do other calculations look very very
different
but the point is conceptually they're
really just three terms that are
entering into all of these rates and the
three terms are very natural
one's a geometric curvature term
one is how the noise aggregates and one
is measuring how large your model is
right
so that's the point that's a
deterministic result
and
it has two essentially geometric
assumptions this curvature condition and
a decomposability condition
where probability enters is in verifying
that you can find a a pre-specified
choice of lambda n that does satisfy
that bound
and to do that you need to assume things
about your model and you need to do some
um some tail bounds and so on
but sort of high level you can see
there's a road map here of how you might
derive bounds for many models
so any questions about that yeah
yes
um
no so
not immediately because i was kind of
assuming um
i'm assuming things that are lower
bounded by quadratics square root would
not be
the reason why square root of 2 doesn't
depend on it is because when you take
the derivative of
l 2 you get just this
but if you take the derivative of square
root of l 2 you get this normalized by
itself you get a self-normalized
quantity and when you self-normalize
that normalizes out the variance
so this kind of analysis looking at
score functions will tell you why square
lusu has this nice property but it
wouldn't pop out of this
yeah it's a good question
any other questions yeah uh how
difficult is it to uh get a handle on
lambda when you switch to say logistic
loss or just keep it at lasso but with a
logistic loss instead of l2 uh it's not
particularly hard
um
well so if you look at any generalized
linear model
what you'll get is you'll get a zero
mean random variable which is sort of a
sample mean by minus a population
if i was doing l1 i would again just
have a maximum
um for glms let's say let's say the
cumulative function is has a upper
bounded second derivative
those deviations are sub-gaussian so the
same thing would hold
um poisson is hard actually i think
you've worked on poisson or maybe
rebecca has poisson is hard because
um
yeah it doesn't have a its link function
is is kind of or its cumulative function
is a bit nasty but for anything logistic
is very straightforward
yeah logistic is fine
uh yeah
why
term is tolerance didn't enter your rate
it entered in some preconditions why is
that natural
um so the reason the tolerance enters is
because
when i compare this to this
exactly this squared is going to come
out
and i need somehow that
that this gets dominated by that so it
comes out in
using this condition to establish
curvature in good directions
if i do the more general oracle version
let me just do that quickly
right so this is a general oracle result
um
so shivran was asking why didn't your
tolerance come out in the rate it will
come out in the rate here here you have
to look at the worst case of lambda n
and tau
and
you'll get two terms
but a high level so what's important
here is this is the generalization
there's no assumptions on the vector
you take any subspace m
and you get a bound that involves how
much you would have paid to estimate
something if it lay in the subspace
and then you get a general approximation
error term
right so we did l1 i just mentioned l1
so in l1
you project onto the orthogonal
complement
right the orthogonal complement of this
is just things that are
zero everywhere on s
so this is exactly the tail sum this is
actually theta star s complement that's
the approximation area you would have
paid in l1
but if you do a matrix problem with
nuclear norm this will be a tail sum of
your singular values again a natural
thing to have happen
okay any other questions
i think i'm nearing the end i'm not
going to finish everything i have
so there's a branching point
think
um
there's some cute results which i'm
going to skip
there's cute results about adaptivity to
unknown structure
that i will leave in the slides for you
let me just talk quickly about low rank
matrices
let me just rederive rates for low rank
matrices quickly
what you'll see is the rates look very
different than sparse vectors but high
level it's exactly the same things that
are coming out
okay so let's just analyze this
semi-definite program where we have a
least squares cost
one instance of this could be matrix
completion that's a particular case of
this setup
we have a nuclear norm
some of the singular values
and
let me just analyze the simple case
where these xi's are random sub-gaussian
projections
but let me analyze it over a slightly
interesting set just for fun
let's analyze it over the set of the lq
ball of near low rank matrices this is a
generalization of vector lq balls where
you look at the singular values
and you ask that the singular values
decay at a certain rate
right so for q equals zero these are
exactly low rank matrices
for q between 0 and 1 these have a fast
singular value decay
okay so here's a quality of that result
that if you set the regularization
parameter in a somewhat different way
why is this coming out i'll sketch the
i'll show you the proof of it quickly in
a second so that's to be larger than
this
you have curvature then you will get
this rate
and that rate is also minimax optimal
it's it's unimprovable
so let me just sketch why do these
different terms come out
um
what i'll actually prove for you quickly
i'll just prove q equals zero
when q is zero then r zero is exactly
the rank you're estimating over rank r
matrices
r is the rank
q is zero this becomes one so let's just
let me sketch out that quickly the more
general result again is is
requires trading off approximation and
estimation
okay so what does our general
prescription say it says
in this case we're looking at a nuclear
norm right we're regularizing a matrix
with the nuclear norm
so it says first compute the dual norm
and i argued for you guys before that
the dual norm
is the operator norm
the maximum singular value
right then what the theory says is it
says compute the score function of your
model evaluated at the truth
so if we do it for a least squares loss
on a matrix problem
the score function is a matrix it's a
random matrix
and
if you had a linear model the score
function would look like this
the x i
right these are your noise variables
that's what you've added
these are observed quantities these are
x i's for instance in matrix completion
these would be mask matrices randomly
zero everywhere except for a position a
one
and so what i need to do is i need to
look at this random matrix and i need to
derive a tail bound on this random
matrix right so there might be depending
on your model there can be more or less
work in doing that but at least the
recipe is clear
right so that's the probabilistic part
of the calculation
now
this is a very simple model it's just a
toy but if these are actually random
gaussian matrices
let's condition on the noise
then this whole thing is a random
gaussian matrix with variance that
depends on
the l2 norm of the ws
but um so condition on w this is just a
random gaussian matrix
and i mentioned this morning that for
random gaussian matrices there's lots of
of concentration and tail bounds
essentially you can show that in the
gaussian case that random variable is
upper bounded by
eight sigma times square root of the
dimension over n
the two dimensions so that's that's a
high probability bound
on the dual norm of the score function
and that ensures that
my my theory applies
okay so that's the dual norm bound and
then what's the last thing i need to do
well what's the right model space to
look at here well the right model space
is
your model space is going to be a set of
rank r matrices
in particular you can look at
the set of matrices that share
the same left and right singular vectors
as the true matrix
and if you look at the worst case of the
nuclear norm over the frobenius norm
over rank r matrices how large can that
be
so if i have a space of of rank r
matrices
how much bigger can the sum of the
singular values be than the l2 norm of
the singular values
right you have essentially r numbers to
play with you only have rank r this is
equal to root r
right so now you can see where the terms
come from this comes from the choice of
regularizer
that comes from measuring the size of
the subspace and the gamma comes from a
curvature condition
all right so that rate looks totally
different than sparse vector estimation
but
um if we just think of a high level it's
it's really just these three ingredients
coming into play
right you're just seeing different
instantiations of of noise measurements
and of subspace measurements
um
and to get the the more general version
then you again have to play the usual
oracle game
rq yes
the right dependence
in the lower bounds or is that
um over the relevant range
um there's some corner cases it's not
totally optimal
um but let me just clarify
um clarify the question
right so his point is that you're using
l using nuclear norm regularization
you don't know q your method does not
know q
but the method is what a statistician
calls adaptive because
it attains a bound that depends on q and
actually depends on q in the optimal way
so yeah when you do the lower bounds
it's again the same recipe you have to
compute metric entropies of
lq balls of matrices and so on so
there's some technicalities but
this is this is unimprovable
yeah
so it is an interesting case that
these are all cases where convex
estimators seem to be achieving optimal
rates
meaning that even if you could implement
some non-convex or horrible exponential
time search you're not going to do
substantially better you might improve
the constant and there is a lot of work
people do worry about constants i have
not been i've been very sloppy but in
terms of scaling laws it is sort of
interesting these cases are optimal
sort of an open question there seem to
be developing cases where convex methods
are not currently known to be optimal
and one is sparse pca which essentially
is a problem where you have a matrix
that is sparse and low rank at the same
time
they're very simple methods that achieve
consistency but they don't achieve
minimax rates they're not as good as um
what you would get out of a an
exponential time search
so that's i think sort of an interesting
thing to keep your eye on there are
cases where convexity seems to be
optimal and adaptively optimal but there
could be gaps and i think understanding
those those gaps could be interesting
so that's basically all i had to say um
i guess i'll wrap that right up there
thanks
yeah we're done for now uh
so back in here for one more talk it is
a bootcraft you should be tired that's a
good sign
i'm back in here